das ist hier links getränke kann die
geplante raus so ein koloss bleibt als
mögliche bieter vor
[Musik]
dann müsste man die autos zum parken und
papa parkplatz mal mein auto
jetzt bin ich mal gespannt wie der sich
anstellt
juli herzlich willkommen beim neuen
video was wir heute vorabend sag ich
euch gleich ich muss jetzt erst mal das
auto wieder dahin stellen weil das ist
immer so kompliziert bei uns da ist man
die brink's jetzt hin
ich melde mich gleich so etwas klappt
herzlich willkommen beim ein video habe
ich ja grad schon gesagt es sollte ein
bisschen stressig auf jeden fall habe
ich heute einiges vor wir haben auch
schon 21 uhr jetzt gleich deswegen ich
muss eigentlich ein parkhaus finden das
ganze durchführen zu können und zwar
erkläre ich euch den rest einfach gleich
also wir fahren jetzt erst mal los ich
muss den kollegen von mir abholen und
dann fahren wir weiter und dann machen
wir das und habe es gleich so läuft
jetzt hab ich kurz zeit auf jeden fall
wir suchen jetzt ein parkhaus weil es
schon dementsprechend dunkel ist und ich
habe wirklich schon ziemlich oft in den
kommentaren gelesen dass ich mal ein
video über machen soll was da so alles
drin ist oder was der kann aber
irgendwie sowas halt ein bisschen
erklären und ich wollte so ein bisschen
kombinieren von wegen diesen watts in my
car tech ich weiß aber dass noch kein
von früher wo leute einfach zeigen was
dem autor bei mir hat sich schon
ziemlich viel scheiß angesammelt und
eigentlich müsste ich das erst mal
waschen weil ich habe ihn gestern so
selber per hand gewaschen aber hier sind
überall so die liebevoll eklige mainz
das hat noch eine waschstraße auf wollen
wir mal waschen gehen komme was man will
jedes erst mal waschen und dann machbar
danny watts in my car tech mit vielen
coolen ja mal gucken was wird ich habe
jetzt so leute was straße schon zu aber
wir haben jetzt hier sowas gefunden ich
glaube das geht noch also ich mich jetzt
mal geld rein werfen weil das ding ist
ich brauche eigentlich nur ein bisschen
wasser damit diese ganzen schmutzigen
abdruck oder was wenn man das weggehen
muss erst schauen ist und dann musst du
musst du jetzt noch sexy musik eindringt
daraus könnten sich wie kaugummi fällen
ganz wichtig wichtig was soll ich jetzt
glanz spielen und abspülen
weil ich du hast nicht mehr gelang
ich will dass die ganze zeit noch weiter
lehrgeld erfolg bereits mit zwei anderen
ich kann jetzt ja ich weiß ich hab jetzt
nicht ich habe euch gleich aber auch
nicht zu sagen ja
er glänzt auf jeden fall wiederkommen
wieder schafft sich das segment so
deutsche wir gehen jetzt zum parkhaus
und dann geht es weiter so leicht wieder
messen parkhaus gefunden und zwar ich
glaube ich mache das jetzt hier sehen
wir denn hin und dann erkläre ich ein
bisschen und zeige ich weiß nicht alles
so im auto herum fliegen hasst aber
schon wieder viel zu lange let's go so
leute ja ich weiß eigentlich gar nicht
viel sagen wir fangen erst mal also
darum wirklich viele nachgefragt was da
so drin ist also ist ja auch logisch
würde mich auch interessieren ich sag
mal so die die eh viel ahnung von autos
haben die wir das gar nicht interessiert
aber am sonntag coole sachen ist auf
jeden fall drin war das jetzt einfach
für so ein beispiel
wir haben hier das ist eigentlich wie
bei jedem auto was halt etwas neuer ist
diesen engine start stopp knopf wenn man
denn an macht dann geht das auto
logischerweise was ganz gut ist wenn man
den rückwärtsgang geht hier dann kann
man da sehen wo man hinfährt rückwärts
damit man halt nicht so wie ich
andauernd gegen irgendwelche bayer fährt
das coolste drin sind eigentlich diese
vier nationen nun kann man einmal also
ja dass das verantwortlich das hier ist
die traktionskontrolle das heißt das
wenn man das jetzt praktisch ausmacht
können die reifen durchdrehen und wenn
man es ein hat dann er nicht und dieser
knopf ist auch super da können wir das
lenkgefühl von normal auf sport oder
aufkommen vorstellen ich habe das
eigentlich immer auf normal japan geht
das ganze ein bisschen leichter ist
eigentlich auch ganz cool und das hier
ist der wichtigste knopf hier kann man
nämlich von normal auf sport stellen
oder auf rennstrecke oder auf schnee und
nässe
da hab ich noch nicht ausprobiert weil
wir haben noch keinen schnee hier kannst
du einfach bisschen kälter machen oder
ein bisschen wärmer ich kann man zb voll
aufdrehen
aber das sind ja eigentlich alles so
sachen wie jucken ein gar nicht aber ist
natürlich ganz schön wenn das man ebenso
hier angezeigt wird
das ist einmal kurz wieder abholen
lassen so was dann auch noch ganz cool
ist man kann hier einiges umstellen ich
hab selber noch nicht alles
herausgefunden es wird viele coole
features
wir können ja hier mal gucken so wir
haben jetzt nämlich den bordcomputer
fordere ich kann das wirklich kann man
einfach im film so leute und zwar kann
man jetzt aus dem bordcomputer rausgehen
und sie dann hier so ein paar
einstellungen wir ganz einfach hier auf
einstellung ich zeige jetzt einfach mal
das coolste oder meiner meinung nach das
cool sein ich brauche man es nicht aber
es natürlich ganz entspannt wenn man mal
die farbe wechseln möchte oder einfach
andauernd dieses violett jetzt hier
sieht und sich dann denkbar jetzt wer
grün auch mal wieder ganz schön dann
wählt man hier einfach mike aller aus
und guckt dann hier bei den
messinstrumenten und stellten zum
beispiel auf grün weiß blau oder rot
finde ich auch cool orange steht auch
ganz meister und wir lassen es ist
einfach auf rot und dann kann man auch
passen doch dieses ambiente licht hier
farbe ambiente liegt machen wir auch mal
auf rot ja dann sieht das so aus er
hierzu vielleicht doch wir sind auch ein
paar apps drauf aber die sind irgendwie
auch nicht interessant hier kannst du
musik drauf spielen so hört jetzt will
ich mal gerade steigen weil eben aus
[Musik]
achso hinten sind übrigens nur zwei
notfall sitzt sie sind aber nicht mehr
also da kannst du praktisch wenn du
jetzt größer als 170 bis nicht
vernünftig sitzen so was ich da noch
sagen kann was man ziemlich gut gefällt
und wenn man ihn auf macht also man
braucht gar kein schlüssel eigentlich
der schlüssel um in der nähe sein
man legt hier seinen finger drauf und
das auto wird auf und geht auch wieder
zu genauso dann hat man hier noch einmal
das muster leuchten warum auch immer
und was mega cool aussieht vor allem
wenn es ganz dunkel es ist dieses
wörtchen hier aber zu machen dazu so
laut ich jetzt vielleicht mal damit wir
auch mal auf dieses worts einmal
klarkommen also das werde ich jetzt zum
auto drin ist was ich halt über diese
drei wochen schon angesammelt hat man
kann ihn einfach aufbauen indem man ganz
doch den kofferraum auf man mir und ich
muss ganz ehrlich sagen ich hab selber
keine ahnung was wir jetzt gleich finden
wir haben ja hier sind meine spur
ich habe ich schon vergessen ich habe
mich letztes gefragt diese schuhe sind
sich gerade dass sie hier baute sie hier
ich frag mich so bauen dass ich das
handy damit ist dann eine frage mit ja
ich hatte das passt ja frisch
das ist eine legia die ist nämlich für
den mag so also diese hier ist für markt
mag wenn du das siehst ja ich hab die im
auto immer dabei du musst sie nur
abholen was wir ja hier haben wir
autogrammkarten von mir wenn wir eine
möchte dann könnt ihr einfach mein auto
aufbrechen und die völlig hinten raus
nehmen bei dieser sache weiß ich jetzt
selber nicht was das ist
die briten wiesen dies ist ein
verbandskasten immer also wenn ihr mal
blut ist da haben wir bescheid ich komm
vorbei ich mach das mal so man muss ja
auch auf einmal auch so in drei jahren
ist das trendy dann haben alle hunger
das bin ich alex w danke dafür habe ich
es nicht geschenkt bekommt das ist er da
habe ich auch vermisst jetzt habe ich
auch wieder
also ich habe gehört dass das teil auch
noch irgendwelche features hat so
irgendwie nachtbeleuchtung oder
irgendwie so specials aber damit habe
ich mich selber noch nicht beschäftigt
und habe absolut keine ahnung jetzt lese
ich bestimmt wieder einen kommentar die
hütchen auto beschäftigt sich mit man
kann zum beispiel vorstellen wie ich
finde es gar nichts weil sozusagen die
halten mich alle die sich mit autos
ausgeben
ich kenne mich irgendwie so
beschleunigung von
wie viel welche drehzahl das macht so
von null auf hundert meter hoch gelegen
kann ja in bewegung so was kann ich
irgendwie glaube ich umstellen aber das
habe ich mich noch nicht so gern im
sportmodus kanzlers einstellen gucken
wir gehen jetzt hier mal ein sportmodus
ok reinigungs messer und muss wenn dann
drehzahl beschleunigung steinigung von
null auf hundert automatischer start
alter ich glaube ich los oder die
besucher
der misst das dann von nur 100 wie viele
brauchen also du kannst bis 6500
umdrehungen gewinnt das schon ganz gut
also man kann auf jeden fall einiges
vorstellen nur hey mich jetzt wird er
nicht weil ich das noch nicht
ausprobiert habe ich muss ganz ehrlich
sagen ich feiere das auto mega aber ich
kenne mich generell mit autos noch nicht
so gut aus aber das kommt noch
1 kommentar was andere leute so viel
erstmal dazu ich weiß nicht ob ich euch
jetzt schon alles gezeigt hat machen wir
bestimmt auch was ein muss sind das nach
schwächer hier kannst du deinen
sonnenbrille reinlegen
ach so ich habe die mutter habe
vergessen worden
achtung ich kann dazu aber einfach nur
sagen okay da ist was man kurz da gibt's
schon klasse da stehen turbine das ist
hier links getränke kann zugewandt
herausholen cola es bleibt alles
mögliche pipapo so leute so viel erstmal
dazu an den ganzen autokenner ich hoffe
ihr habt ein bisschen seid bitte nicht
zu gemein zu mir den kommentaren danke
an sonst nehmen sonntag wieder sonntag
um 14 uhr gibt es ein neues video chats
oder instagram ab und wir sehen uns
sonntag haut rein